each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
it's my pleasure to introduce chengdong
who's been a research intern this summer
he's been working on the lab of things
and how programming for the lab of
things can be made easy using touch to a
low check thanks sergeant my name is
Jindo I'm a third year PhD student from
Indiana University and at IU I work for
the ethical technology in the homes of
senior group where we develop in test
assisted living technologies that
protect security and privacy for the
senior citizens and I'm very excited to
work with our command and the entire
level things team this summer on the
integration of level things to touch
develop let's see nowadays a large
number of sensors have been Inge stored
inside and outside the houses for
example we have door sensors window
sensors the sensors for temperature
humidity motion and distance and in
addition we might want to control some
of the electronic devices such as our
printers and TVs in which we might not
have any sensors into installed on these
kind of devices to typical questions
people might ask would be how can we
enable the devices and sensors to be
effectively interconnected and for the
academic research that needs to study to
be deployed in a large number of houses
either an effective way to achieve that
level things offers the powerful
framework to deploy the field studies
across different houses and enable easy
data collection from the houses and into
the cloud storage in addition the
framework offers the user of the
capability of remote monitoring the
systems running status and also even
remote updating the applications that
have been installed on this app on this
house a fundamental components of the
level things is the home OS platform the
software platform is running on a local
machine on in each house it's usually a
small
laptop computer and known as the home OS
hubs which connects and interacts with
different types of sensors and devices
the levels thinks is currently focusing
on the home environments however the
framework can be actually deployed to
many other environments for example the
nursing houses of office buildings and
even in cars right and there's nothing
stopping us from deploying this
technology seeing these environments now
let's take a closer look at the
different layers of the local home OS we
mentioned in the previous slide in the
existing model the home OS platform
consists of four layers let's start with
the very bottom one the device discovery
is taken care of by a few small programs
named the scouts if the device is needs
to be paired or communicated with the
platform then the homo wise drivers will
also take care of that as well basic
functionalities of the devices for
example of taking pictures for the
cameras or monitoring the door opening
events for the door sensors are written
in the homo eyes drivers and also the
management and access control
functionalities are part of the level
things functionality I mean the platform
itself and on the very top layer we do
have the applications we have a few
applications that actually allow the
user to interact with different
components within the platform and my
contribution this summer in this
internship is to build a new layer on
top of on top of the application layer
which is called the lightweight
application layer and to allow the
simple applications to be written by
only you know a few lines of code and
allow people to write the their programs
on level things more easy and I have to
also mention that also have worked on
some work on the device connectivity and
device functionality layer which enables
the Kinect sensor to be connected
to the level things platform and I will
soon have a demo that showcase of the
integration of the three great
technologies level things touch the ball
up and the Kinect sensor ok some more
details about the Kinect sensor drivers
on the level things with a large set of
capabilities on the kinect sensor i
define the following functionalities and
operations for the driver any
application on the level things platform
can ask for the latest image of taken by
the Kinect sensor or it can subscribe to
that event to receive all future I mean
all future color images that are taken
by the sensor it can also get the depths
information and for depth information we
enable both the depths matrix and the
depths images to be returned by the the
Kinect sensors driver on the lap of
things platform the level things driver
also enables audio recording so you can
actually indicate you know a duration of
the water recording and will record for
you and store the file locally on the
hub and at last it returns the detected
skeleton information and stored it
locally so that any application can just
fetch the file and for further analysis
ok so the levels things it's a very
powerful framework and can support a
large number of applications and many of
them are very innovative to be created
based on the local platform different
devices and drivers I'm sorry devices
and sensors and also the cloud
components itself the traditional level
things application follow a browser
server model so in order to write an
application on level things you really
have to follow the WCF service approach
right so you first have to start visual
studio and created projects and you have
to define a number of endpoints and the
functionalities which then
and here I have I service CS you have to
expose a number of endpoints and then
another very important file for creating
the level things app would be the
service stops ES file where you actually
implement this functionalities and the
endpoints you have already indicated and
the developers might also want to write
some code to kind of respond to some
standard levels things events for
example what actions to take when a new
device is registered with the platform
right this is something that the
developer needs to write about and we
can imagine that's the entry-level
developer to take a week or so to get
themselves familiar with the entire
framework and write some code on C sharp
and also JavaScript maybe index dot HTML
and all of these things and they might
have to write maybe a hundred lines of
code to implement the basic
functionalities however we have to
realize that the it's very hard to write
the dinette application on level things
for a reason right because they're very
powerful we can create actually a
projects to do image processing we can
do motion detection a lot of cool
functionalities however we have to also
realize that there are also some of the
user population that is also from the
field of Nursing for example and health
informatics and these users are not
necessarily hot core developers they
might not know about C sharp or visual
studio at all but we would like to allow
them to create certain applications that
are only involving very simple logic so
for example let's imagine that a user is
has the level things of system deployed
in their houses and then he wants to
write a program to just visualize the
data he collected from the sensor and
this is a very simple logic and we don't
need
to the user to write that whole dot CS
files and HTML files and the jas files
to implement that and we should allow
the writing the code to be simple and
let's review the requirements again and
see if we can somehow reduce the number
of requirements but still achieve the
optimal performance and the
functionalities that we can get from the
level things platform the first question
would be can we actually Lymon age the
requirements for C sharp and visual
studio it's actually okay as long as we
can make writing the program as easy as
doing a few function cos and combine the
function calls in this case this end
users can simply just create some user
on some end users side I mean the
client-side scripts right for example
JavaScript and just do the function cost
and get the results and if we are able
to achieve this goal then we don't need
to require visual studio installation
and the use of C sharp in this case and
also i have to mention that this is a
scenario that is that is specific to a
particular circumstances right so we
only think that this would work if you
are only interested in some very simple
logic not something that we would do for
example image processing or the audio
processing and motion detection and we
would like to offer the great
programming experience to the level
things users but we would also want to
eliminate the changes to be made to our
existing framework and also the local
platform so one of the solutions would
be to build a very special application
on top of the application layer and it's
called the generic application okay we
call this a generic app because it's not
designed just for one or two specific
devices instead it can potentially talk
to everything every sensor and every
device
that is connected to the lap of things
platform the generic app is running on
the level things platform as a WCF web
service and now the problem becomes how
would an end user interacts with the
generic application we can imagine two
ways that the communication would take
place the first one is through the
generic apps homepage like other
applications on the level things
platform our generic app also has a
user-friendly web interface so if you go
to the web page we actually show you
that the developers have to filling out
a and B in this logic so if a which is
that the event happens then we execute
an operation which is B and in this
screen shot the developer actually
choose if the door sensor is triggered
then it will ask the Kinect sensor to
record it audio for an absentee length
and that's what this page tells you and
as you can see from this screen shot the
the logic actually that is embedded in
this web page is kind of fixed to add
the flexibility and also better user
experience to this kind of to this
generic app we have to consider other
ways of talk to of talking to the WCF
service and one of the other option is
to talk to the generic web service
directly of through restful function
calls and of course the developers could
choose to use some third-party
applications to to help the developer
make the call but I mean both of the
operator boast of the methods are okay
and what what what is that my point here
is the generic app really opens up the
world of easily creating the level
things applications and to add
flexibility and better experience we
really need to consider something else
something with a better user experience
and good functionality
and touch develop is something that we
have considered that should be a very
good tool to interact with our level
things of generic at the touch develop
is the technology designed and
implemented by Microsoft Research it's
an app creation of environments for
mobile cloud connected and touch devices
anyone can visit touch develop calm and
work on their own scripts with the help
of touch develop api's the developers
who wants to write a good program can
just reduce the their lines of code that
you know they will need to write and we
choose touch develop to connect to our
generic API for the following reasons
first of all the touch develop has a
very user friendly interface so you just
go to touch of all calm and you make a
few function cause to our generic app
and also touch w calm would offer you
the environments for code debugging it
can show you the variables and also the
stack status which is very cool and in
addition the rich set of AP is our is
actually the second reason that we
choose touch develop touch develop has a
standard API for displaying images and
also the audio so the developers do not
need to worry about how do I actually
implement that and the third one is
mobility just imagine that people have
level things deployed in their houses
and but they might be away from their
home hub with touch develop they might
also be able to write simple programs
with touched with level things and have
it deployed on the heart and the next
one would be to support standard HTTP
and JSON touch develop has a standard
library to make the post cost on to our
jab and also it can create and pass the
JSON object which allows the user to
talk directly to the generic API and the
last one support the export programs
well this function now
is pretty cool because I can actually
create a level things application and
export it as a library so anybody else
who is also interested in using the
level things can also just use my
library and make simply make simple
programs okay for each function call
that the generic flap service provides
there should be at least one function on
the touch to our website to wrap the
input parameters of front end user so
for example send emails is one
functionality that is provided by the
generic valve service and of course
there is something on the touch develop
site that is doing sending emails it
accepts the user inputs and make the
right function call and but on top of
that we might want some other processes
to be standardized for example instead
of just sending a text emails we might
want an image taken by the camera to be
attached right and sending that email
and on the touch develop side we have
made send emails with picture available
as well so including a sending email
with picture and sending emails as two
functions inside the library where we
are enable the users that the developers
to actually choose which one they want
and now let's consider an elderly care
scenario to which the level things
technology can apply one of the
challenges that the senior citizens to
live alone would be the severe risk of
wandering that come with the onset of
dementia and other cognitive
disabilities and elderly actually
suffering from this problems may leave
their house without proper closing or at
an unusual time and just go wandering
the second risk is the social
exploitation now the outers are known to
be you know and wonder about population
and as such are often targeted in
various scams so we do have an existing
dunnet application on the level things
platform that can address this problem
which is the lower self
and in the lore sap it actually make use
of the z-wave door sensor and web camera
and the logic of the alert app is
whenever the door opens it can takes a
picture and then sends that picture as
well as the alerts text through email at
this case to the caregiver and then
upload the picture and also the ler
stacks to Windows Azure from the cloud
and now the question is can we actually
do the same thing with touched of olive
and using the lap of things library yes
we can and I'm going to show you how to
do that can we switch to the demo
machine please ok so what we do is we
first want to go to touch develop calm
and after signing I can find the level
things oh thank you I can find the
library link library right and I would
like to make sure that the level things
library is referenced here and here my
application is called level things demo
and before I write I write anything I
would like to make sure that my url this
is the URL to my level things hot ok and
this URL is included and also i have put
in my email address here so that you
know I I don't have to type it when I'm
receiving the alerts from the front
alerts app and then here i have a few
names defined here which are the
connects name the the cameras named the
azure name and things like that key and
directory the first task would be to
initialize the connection and i will use
that hops URL and just called
initialization function from the lote
library and then i want to make sure
that the wall is actually displaying the
objects in the right order let's first
try something
quickly and see if the level things
platform is running correctly and I want
to make sure that I can do show all the
devices that are currently connected to
this platform so it's just one lines of
code level things and then list all
devices on the hub and there we go I
should be able to run this there we go
so here with only one lines of code I'm
listing all the devices and sensors that
are currently connected to this machine
serving as a homo ass hot up I'll go
through them one by one the first one is
the camera that is actually better
actually part of the laptop and my
connect is the name of this connect and
also a bunch of z-wave sensors and most
importantly we have the door sensor
which is right here and is connected
through the z-wave down go to the to
this platform so it's working let's go
ahead and create the alerts at remember
the first thing that we need to do is we
want to subscribe to the events okay we
want to have the door opening events
deliver to our script right so the first
thing I need to do is to make sure that
level things subscribe to event is
working sorry
oh not take a stream
why
watch events okay so here for watch
event I'm actually subscribing to that
particular events and this particular
function needs to have the device name
which I already have it here entered
it's the door sensors name nope so it
should be it should be X okay very good
should be X and the next one is the
device type this is a sensor so i will
just puts answer here okay and the third
one is a an event name and in this case
it's just get i'm getting the status so
okay this function call is completed to
see any response from on this from this
sensor we need to also create something
like this levels things and we need to
get the new events right so in this case
we want to do get new events okay let's
give it a name sorry this is the name of
the so this is a device name device name
is X I'll put it here and okay so this
particular function returns on two
parameters to output parameters one is
has new its indicate if a new events is
detected and the second one is event
which is the actual events that is
received okay how about we do we ask the
program to sleep for five seconds and
then
I'm sleep okay sleep for five seconds
and then we can make sure that if a new
event is received then we print out the
events how's that let's see has new is
too then we just put the event event is
a structure in this case and we want to
make sure that event device name is
actually print it to the wall okay and
to make sure that it doesn't interfere
with each other I just want to make sure
that okay let's do that and let's ask
the the platform to sleep for 10 seconds
in this case sleep 10 seconds all right
and i think that's it see if I'm
triggering this thing it should get an
event there we go if he actually prints
out the sensor that has been triggered
right and since this is actually a
structure they then it's actually a
structure I can also put other members
for example the time has triggered and
the location that of the sensor in this
loop ok so the next step would be to
make sure that we can trigger the camera
to take a picture right and maybe we can
post that picture to the wall and the
next step I can do it this way let's see
get image okay it's just one lines of
code okay and at this time I'm i need
the device name of the camera so since i
have already put it here i can just say
camera name right and it's actually
returned two variables sorry two
parameters one is picture and one is
pictures stream picture is actually in
picture objects was in the Tosh develop
and pictures string is a base64 encoded
pictures string which can be used for
WCF web service it can be actually
posted back to our lab oh thanks
platform okay so we want to make sure
that the pictures can be posted to wall
post a wall and in this case you should
be able to see an image ok let me
trigger that again there we go it's
myself ok so that's just one line zip
code right and how about sending the
picture to the caregiver through email
it's also one lines of code all right
about doing that email send emails with
picture this is an example that I gave a
few minutes ago for this function to
work you have to put the subject here
the subjects let's make a fake subject
saying that touched follow-up test okay
and the next parameter is the message
itself saying this is a test ok and put
a period here and the third one is the
email address I already have my email
address here so i will just say email
and just use the variable and the force
one is the image that I've like to
attach so in this case it's going to be
the pictures stream all right so I think
that's it I will just run this and once
it's triggered I believe it will take a
picture and it will also send an email
to my email account but it's it may take
a while so I will just show you when
rives alright so this is the alerts at
right when the door opens it will take a
picture and then send the picture to the
email and also potentially the windows
azure cloud and as I mentioned it sioned
in the in the slice and a few slides ago
I also worked on some interconnectivity
stuff which actually enables the
connectivity of the kinect sensor with
the level things platform so can we
actually replace the valve sensor the
sorry the web camera with the Kinect
sensor and provides a rich set of
information is this is actually my next
demo but I would just make changes to
the existing one to save some time and
just show you how oh there you go our
alerts that received or just first show
you that so this is the Lord stress I
I've seen at that sense from our test
script okay through touch develop all
right so let's do something to the
existing alerts tab and make use of this
guy the kinect sensor and catch the
caller information the depths
information and also record an audio how
do we do that especially pretty simple
since we already have the logic built
here we will just replace the get image
here Wiz get color image connect right
and I have also put the connects name
here so I would just use the variable
connect name and it returns the picture
and picture stream in addition to the
color image I will also be interested in
seeing some depth information and in
this case I would say level things and
then get depths connects
alright and i still need to put my
connect name here and it's also returned
as two strings in this case let's call
it picture death and this one is ok
that's ok pictures strain too and I want
to make sure that both the picture
depths and pictured depp's to is post it
to wall I see this is posed to wall
right let's see one is triggered a while
there you go it takes the color picture
and also returns the depths information
and this is actually the the depth image
that is taken by the Kinect and you can
also get the adapts matrix if they
choose to do that and use the right api
on the level things library and how
about we add the third functionality to
the to the app which is recording like
record the audio for 30 of maybe ten
seconds okay let's do that within one
lines of code level things in them how
about audio ok we have a record audio
connect ok as the first parameter I need
to put in connect name and the second is
indicating the the duration so in this
case 10 seconds and we can't actually
want it again and it will sorry we can
just do that Oh another alerts so I need
to trigger that and it will take two
pictures and oh sorry I need ok I need
to find this file so it will actually do
the the audio recording for 10 seconds
and then save the file locally on the
hob so I will need to find this file
right here i will just put okay so okay
so this is the audio recording part
right so and it's working need that and
the next one would be to send the emails
and you already seen that the sending
emails is working and how about we also
get some skeleton information that is
extracted from images that are taken and
in this case we can do level things
and them scattered in information oops
skeleton but I'm sorry I should delete
that skeleton there we go get skeleton
connects at this time I only need to put
skeleton sorry the Kinect name here and
I want to store the results in a local
variable which is stream skeleton and
then i'll post it to wall post a wall
and let's run it again when it's
triggered would take ok it's again
taking the color image and the depth
image will start the audio recording and
there we go the skeleton information
it's actually it's recorded in the local
file and any application on the level of
things who are interested in this kind
of information can go ahead and grab the
file and pass it and do some interesting
stuff with that so any questions about
the two demos all right can we switch
back to the to the presentation all
right and as our next steps would like
to test the usability of the level of
things of touch develop library after we
deployed the level things a platform in
people's houses it would be an
interesting to see how end users would
actually interact with the touched
enabled programming environments what
type of levels things application they
want to write and for how long can they
create that kind of application privacy
is another issue beside researchers who
deploy the experiments in people's
houses we also expect the levels things
users who may be know about touch
develop and want to use that to write
simple programs to write simple programs
but
we also want to know how do we isolate
the resources that is allocated to each
of the touch developed scripts like how
do we prevent users to use each other's
devices apps and local storage how do we
prevent that and this is of Steel the
research questions we will need to
answer in the next step and at last the
speech based programming we do realize
that at UC Davis professor gending su
has implemented that synthesizer to
capture the key words of the end user
speech and automatically match the
closest comments on touch develop it
will be a next step an exciting value of
research if we can expand this kind of
work on to the lap of things library so
that the level things user can just
briefly describe the task to be
completed and then the synthesizer would
capture that keywords and match the
corresponding level things events for
them and at last I would like to thank
the entire level things group and also
touch developed group for your help and
guidance and I have to say it's really
fun to be here on this summer as a
summer intern and thanks very much for
your time to come here and I'd like to
take any questions you may have
come on
so good everything on your laptop but I
guess ideally I would have my smartphone
or tablet record with some scripting and
then okay you don't look at a set of
house but it's just one house what's the
idea I needed some computer somewhere
you you you were needed to like the
level things to run in your home
environments right this is the hub that
is running on your on inside your house
and at the same time you can actually
work on this work on your scripts fun
anywhere you can just access that
because for each hub we have enabled the
remote access I believe that's I might
not be the right person this is a very
low end 159 insist universe sucks but it
or PC of they say all you need is a
Windows 8 machine running with the lab
things homo it's often on it and when we
77 on so as you connect devices so the
device is right now are seen it and
connect or not the cell plan to get sat
down I mean what exactly the potential
that wonder if you totally separate user
interface from how the single ons and
unable to maintain
another Windows 7 PC but you'll need a
pc running presumably all the time in
the home so that's all the scenarios can
come if you have a PC so this is the
server so bc is the place where all
interconnectivity happens with the
devices deployed in ideally it should be
on all the time so any pc will do that
indifference or after well yes but the
lab of things gives you an you know an
interface whether that is loud and if
you're asking you whether or not you can
run helplessly yeah we have a move
upgrade if you're either you if you
don't care much they are a single a
little steak course amadoras there was
no youth interaction whatsoever just
dots for the am in the future we will
get vm has issues I think Microsoft's
hypervisor does not do us be any
directions so you have USB devices you
run need to use their
but I think the answer is the precise
answer your question is will tomorrow
saying like any any PC that runs with a
seven or eight will do the cheapest you
can probably find is 151 dollars the
reason indie studio is on is because
it's getting events from the devices so
it fits off and you door opens you could
know that it opened them so this the
utility goes down if you smell or
bizarre but with respect to windows
update and stuff if you don't want
security a you can always switch
them off yeah which is actually yeah I'm
a salvar Craig I'm from the embedded
team but for Windows Embedded so one of
the products we have windows in Venice
77 it's a component wise to us so lets
you put these type of scenarios you pick
and choose a component your models they
want the uso el want no pads and will
get updates pertinent service and
they'll have
you can exclude them from your OS in one
of the things regard you know that is
one of the products we have right now in
we are thinking about future products
right having similar capabilities for
these types of scenarios como a lot of
things what was that protocol windows
embedded standard Oh standard rings can
you pick which version have done in
front where you run oh yes like so we
need 4.5 by the way 77 way doesn't
really matter what's the minimum skew
you brought that on yeah what's this
focus for the smallest footprint I don't
have to go on the PM sun so i can
remember exactly it's in megabytes it
right your hundreds of megabytes not the
gigabytes so
I have another question so your script
had a start but they were basically
starting in script and then checking if
there was an event right now for the
scenario described this will work it
would want this thing to run come see
everything happened so far with you man
uh we could just leave the thing running
I mean currently we can actually make
some function call and you know because
the rules app which is the generic app
is actually running on the server or the
hub so we can just leave something on
the on the hop to run for a while and
let the hop take care of you know the
functionalities and we can just make the
the script to start the functionality
and let the hub take care of the rest so
that you can actually close that you
have a plan to be able to push a scraped
into the server oh yeah that's that's
also something that we need to consider
not just because of the functionality
but also some some of the security
issues that we were considering like
because we want to turn on the the
authentication part and that is offered
by the level things platform and there's
several issues with the the cookies and
also the tokens things like that so
we're considering that and we're having
a discussion
yes how easy is it to add new devices
and sensors so you can just call them by
name you mean add a new type of sensor
or add a new like I don't know if you do
something could you connect to someone
and your nest uh yeah I can last a short
can we switch back to the demo machine
please the voice commands so this is my
laptop and it's the home of the levels
things dashboard and where you can
actually add new devices through this
portal and if something that has not
been registered will show up here and
you can actually click on one of them
and give it actually a friend in the
name for example webcam to and choose
the location and also choose the
applications that actually have access
to this device so in this case I can
choose that and will show up in all the
applications that have access to of this
and in the rules app which I mentioned
you will see a number of devices that is
actually connected to the platform it
doesn't have a very pretty you I but you
get the idea of the functionality parts
vices are being picked up by the Wi-Fi
on the computer and order bluetooth yeah
as long as this connected and it's
recognized for the right pilot from OS
platform at I think you were seen for
the foot devices that we already have
the drivers yeah like for life
no IP Bates camera it would just give
that setup flow just bored and we have a
driver for a bunch of z-wave devices so
an easy way you guys would just work but
for Kinect you know yeah there that you
a lot of light the driver yeah good
night but it's all just that net go yeah
so let's keep my upon the phone westside
on what happened to the touch to those
things because then I guess let's use
this becomes developing too expensive
library right you I mean eventually
we'll have wild function corresponds to
one function call that is designed for
generic app so you don't have to write
additional api's we will make all the
APS that we discussed available as part
of the library so that people can just
go ahead and use the use their menu it's
actually not related to the to the
device type if you're adding a new type
of device you are still using the level
things model so you can just refer to
those I mean you when you send you have
180 itís and the commands to the think
I'd right and then you put the string
that which says what the command is
right yeah ah now I guess it would be
probably better to have a separate
library for the no I conditioning
which was cut metals set temperature and
finally that right september's you can
you which would be a command and you
could kind of presenting by just putting
the sink set temperature that you can
all value right that's all very
discoverable set temperature is up well
they're they're actually uh two ways of
approaching that one way is because set
temperature if you do have that as part
of the operation to the AC which is a
device type right if you have that
defined in the lap of things platform
then the rules app will be able to
return that operation for you you you
you don't have to make any guess because
I do have a basic functionality to tell
you that there is an operation called
set temperature and then yes justjust
Liberty the reason this works is that
device functionality itself is extracted
in from west so that gets expressed in
terms of roads the terms because then
the service classes that have operations
which are essentially operations like
set temperature wat zeg does is that
basically takes all those wrong
definitions and he converts them into
something that can be called so if you
wrote an homage driver or enroll or
something that all of those operations
would immediately become visible to his
stuff without actually doing anything
special beyond writing just the mos
driver we will be showing here as part
of the option for example the kinect
sensor and i do have the following
functionalities available to that
particular row and it's a new one so i
can just like a class and you can go to
court and you can see it's basically a
class essentially that you defined a
bunch of operations
and he loved this when they stink Jing
thank you